nous sommes six ans ce soir dans cette
salle statistiquement il y a trois cents
personnes stressées parmi nous si c'est
pas vous c'est votre voisin moi aussi
j'ai été stressé très stressée est très
anxieuse je voudrais vous raconter
comment aujourd'hui je ne suis plus avec
l'aide de mes images au moment où j'ai
pris cette photographie je perdais tous
mes repères
j'avais coché toutes les cases de ma
liste
cette liste qu'on se fait avec des buts
à atteindre avant tel ou tel âge
pour moi c'était mariage enfants maison
comme dans le conte de fées pourtant je
n'étais pas cette femme épanouie cette
mère comblée
comme j'avais prévu et quand je rentrais
chez moi j'ai tout fait dans la maison
de conte de fées
mon couple était percutée par un jumbo
jet avec écrit divorce dessus c'était
pour moi comme l'effondrement des tours
jumelles
j'étais dans ma catastrophe planétaire
et c'est là quelques semaines avant mes
40 ans alors que ma vie était en plein
chaos qui est arrivé le bug je suis dans
le cabinet d'un médecin et s'étonne
m'annonce que j'ai un cancer un cancer
du sein il m'explique que tout d'abord
il va m'opérer pour m'enlever un saint
et qu'ensuite je rêve des traitements je
perdrais peut-être mes cheveux et puis
il me fait un arrêt de travail
il dit que ça peut durer longtemps
plusieurs années mon cerveau est déjà
tellement plein de problèmes à régler et
d'incertitudes
là je me sens comme un lapin dans les
phares d'une voiture
je suis incapable de bouger de réfléchir
je suis totalement terrorisé il faut
savoir que quand j'étais enfant j'ai
perdu deux de mes grands parents et
trois oncles et tantes de cancer
fulgurant j'ai grandi avec ces gens
j'étais proche d'eux leur disparition a
profondément marqué et là c'est mon tour
pour moi avoir un cancer ça voulait dire
mourir comme à partir de ce moment là
j'ai été tout le temps angoissé même
respirer est devenu difficile quand
j'étais oppressé j'étais tout le temps
ce lapin dans les phares de la voiture
qui voit sa mort arriver et je pensais
tout le temps mes enfants mes enfants
c'est ce que j'aimais de ma vie j'ai
aimé entendre leurs rires et les
regarder jouer faire des bêtises
bien sûr à partir de ce jour là quand je
regardais mes enfants je voyais des
orphelins le médecin avait dit aussi
votre pronostic est favorable pronostics
c'est un terme de courses hippiques
les médecins utilisent pour vous
expliquer que vous n'allez peut-être pas
mourir mais qui n'en sont pas certains
j'ai pensé que si j'étais un cheval de
course 7 hommes miseraient peut-être sur
moi et je crois qu'il a voulu me
rassurer
lorsqu'il a ajouté votre vie ne sera
plus jamais comme avant
j'y mets pas ma vie avant alors j'ai
préféré comprendre qu'elle serait mieux
et ça m'a aidé pendant les opérations
pendant les chignons et la radiothérapie
et quand j'ai perdu mes cheveux
c'était comme la lumière au bout du
tunnel un long tunnel qui a duré trois
ans et pour tenir bon malgré l'anxiété
et les effets secondaires des
traitements
j'ai cherché des solutions pour que mes
enfants est une mère vivante mais une
mère vivante et debout parce que
sincèrement
certains jours je n'arrivais pas à me
lever
une amie m'a amené marché bon j'ai mais
pas du tout ça a marché
à la limite à new york pour aller faire
les expos du sopi crois pas mais bon
elle avait une bonne idée elle a bien
fait d'insister
ça m'a fait du bien tout de suite être
dans la nature me vider la tête et s'en
tire mon corps fatigué en action me
réconfortait j'ai pris l'habitude
d'aller au parc près de chez moi
régulièrement mais bon au bout de
cinquante tours de parc
il fallait quand même que je rentre à la
maison et donc je suis allé voir un psy
des thérapeutes
j'ai fait de l'homéopathie de
l'acupuncture
j'ai même vu un chaman et j'ai vu plein
de livres pour me renseigner pour
comprendre ce qui m'arrivait j'ai lu
guérir de david servan-schreiber
j'ai trouvé beaucoup d'infos et j'ai
découvert les recherches des
neurosciences sur le stress et l'anxiété
et ça m'a vraiment aidé de comprendre ce
que je vivais et de savoir que d'autres
gens vivaient aussi je me suis senti
moins puissante
et j'ai essayé l'hypnose
j'ai fait des séances de mdr j'ai
utilisé des techniques de relaxation
profonde pour me préparer aux opérations
pour la reconstruction de mons et
ensuite j'ai commencé à faire de la
méditation
ce sont ces méthodes qui mon esprit
inspiré le projet forces naturelles
j'ai voulu à travers ce projet partager
les bienfaits qu'elle n'a qu'elle m'a
porté
et puis c'était important pour moi de
m'exprimer artistiquement mais mon
travail artistique m'a beaucoup aidé
pendant cette période
ça m'a donné beaucoup de force ou de
trois ans il a fallu que je retourne au
travail l'arrêt maladie était terminée
et comme je ne pouvais plus faire le
métier que je faisais avant j'ai fait
une reconversion professionnelle
j'allais dire une reconstruction ça
c'était déjà fait j'ai fait une
reconversion professionnelle
je voulais rebondir dans le monde du
travail
après m'être traîner dans les couloirs
de la clinique pendant trois ans alors
j'ai fait une formation à plein temps
avec des stages en entreprise et un
mémoire de 40 pages à rendre le problème
c'est de la mémoire
je n'en avais plus
et puis après quatre ans de lutte
je saturais en fait j'ai fait un burn
out avant la fin de la formation est de
toute façon j'en pouvais plus de
chercher les solutions
j'étais au bout du rouleau et je n'avais
plus d'énergie
alors je n'ai pas eu le choix
cet été-là l'été de montbernard août
j'ai appris la patience
j'ai appris à être patiente et j'ai
accepté que ça prendrait beaucoup plus
de temps que je ne le pensais de me
remettre de me rétablir et beaucoup plus
de temps que je le voulais de reprendre
une vie normale avec un métier avec un
travail et puis j'ai accepté de vivre
avec le doute avec le fait de ne pas
savoir de quoi mon avis mon avenir
serait fait j'ai dit adieu aux listes
inscrites dans le marbre
je me suis fait à l'idée que vivre c'est
être comme un funambule sur son fil il
ne pas avoir de certitude c'est
difficile n'est-ce pas ça fait peur
je voudrais vous raconter l'histoire du
cac c'est un récit de dino buzzati que
j'ai lu quand j'étais adolescente et que
j'aime beaucoup il m'a suivi toute ma
vie et je crois que je l'ait compris cet
été là véritablement c'est l'histoire
d'un homme qui toute sa vie est
poursuivi par un monstre et toute sa vie
il le fuit jusqu'à ce que très vieux il
se décide à l'affronter il n'a plus rien
à perdre ils se préparent à mourir il
s'approche de la bête et le monstre
ouvre sa gueule toute grande et sur sa
langue il lui tend une magnifique perles
qui lui offre avant de disparaître
moi aussi j'ai eu un cadeau cet été là
j'ai compris que les obstacles sur ma
route n'était là que pour donner corps à
toutes les possibilités que m'offre la
vie sur cette image ce ne sont pas les
arbres qu'il faut regarder mais tous les
chemins entre tellement possibilité
tellement d'avenir c'est à ce moment là
que j'ai entendu parler du travail d'un
homme américain qui depuis 30 ans aide
les malades du cancer avec à gérer leur
anxiété leur stress et aussi la douleur
cet homme s'appelle jon kabat zinn il a
créé le programme de réduction du stress
par la pleine conscience
j'ai fait ce programme avant deux mois
quarante minutes tous les jours je me
suis entraîné a juste observé mes
pensées à sentir mes sensations
mes émotions et à les laisser passer en
revenant sur ma respiration à l'hôpital
sainte anne à paris
cette méthode a permis de réduire de
moitié les rechutes dépressive des
malades
ça marche ça a été pour moi une
véritable éducation à la vie jusque dans
les petites choses du quotidien
marchez dans la rue l'esprit libre même
pour venir à bobino parler sur scène
manger faire la cuisine en prenant
plaisir à toutes les sensations parler à
quelqu'un en étant vraiment présente
mes enfants apprécient beaucoup comme
tout le monde j'ai des problèmes mais
aujourd'hui je ne panique plus je garde
mon énergie pour les gérer comme il ya
quelques temps quand mon fils henry
s'est blessé en faisant du skate board
et qu'il a fallu que je la mène
rapidement chez le médecin ou alors cet
hiver quand j'ai dévalé la pente de ski
à plat ventre
peut-être en avant mon calme intérieur
et mon efficacité pour gérer ces
situations
mon moi même surprise c'est totalement
nouveau
je n'avais jamais connu en fait ce qu'à
l'intérieur
ce travail avec la pleine conscience que
j'ai commencé il ya deux ans maintenant
m'a changé profondément
en fait je suis devenu moi même sans mes
réactions anxieuse et mon stress les
neuroscientifiques appelle ça la
plasticité cérébrale
moi ce que je constate c'est que ma joie
de vivre est là et qu'elle reste quoi
qu'il arrive
et aujourd'hui quand je regarde mes
enfants je vois simplement mes enfants
ou plus tôt aujourd'hui mais adolescents
vautré sur le canapé du salon
vous aussi trouver votre méthode trouver
celle qui vous convient pour qu'ensemble
on fasse bouger les lignes de ces
satanés statistiques
c'est important parce que ces méthodes
sont préventives selon le plan cancer
40 % des cas sont liés à des facteurs
ine pardon sont deux sont liés à des
facteurs évitable qui sont dus à nos
modes de vie et à nos comportements
vous savez j'ai un rêve je rêve d'un
pays
je rêve d'un pays où les managers et les
employés dans les entreprises développer
ensemble leurs capacités à la tension un
pays où les conseils des ministres ou
les séances de l'assemblée nationale
commencera par dix minutes de calme et
de silence et si demain nos enfants à
l'école cultiverait leur intelligence
émotionnelle n'ont pas l'heur cuit mais
leur qu eux
imaginez l'évolution de notre société en
une génération
je vous remercie beaucoup